>>Student: It's like, way more rougher.
>>Roshelle: How many of you
noticed that the club soda started
to get bubbles around it and fizz?
Why do you think that's happening?
>>Student: In most sodas, around
the glass, like bubbles appear
and I think the same effect
happened with the candy.
>>Roshelle: The benefits of having
explorations class is keeping the kids
engaged, getting them
to ask those questions.
It just really gets the kids
excited and motivated to learn more.
>>Katie: Explorations, the idea behind
it is creating classes of choice
for children, so that they can sign
up for an interest that they may have.
And then it also provides the
teachers with an incentive to be able
to teach something that
they're very passionate about.
>>Vicky: Each teacher picks a topic
that they're interested in that fits
in our STEAM theme, the science,
technology, engineering, the arts,
or mathematics, and they come up with
eight lessons that go along with it.
And then the kids get to choose which
topic, and you have mixed grade levels.
>>So is the wheel going to go on here?
>>Student: Yeah.
>>Vicky: So we're going
to put the wheels
on which direction, this
way or this way?
>>Student: I think this
way is going to be better.
>>Vicky: Right now, I have toyology,
which is fourth and fifth graders,
and we are going to analyze how toys are
built, what the components are in them,
and then they will apply
that information
and knowledge to make their own toys?
>>Georgette: A blueprint is
like a sketch of your model.
It's what, you want to make
a model, you blueprint it,
and you would have what it looks
like, what it's made out of.
Anyone who really builds
anything would use it
because it scales what
they were going to build.
>>Katie: We make sure that our
kids have a lot of opportunities
to be very curious, to observe,
to wonder, to have a hypothesis,
to find something out, to re-engineer
something and think about the world
around them, how can they contribute?
>>Georgette: We're having
fun, but also learning.
>>Student: It didn't really do
nothing, it just really stayed.
>>Roshelle: The exploration class I'm
teaching is called candy chemistry.
The kids come in and we get to--
like yesterday we did the
Mentos and Diet Coke challenge.
So they get to really do a
lot of science observing.
>>Student: If it has bubbles, it might
like affect the thing you're putting in.
>>Alexa: You learn about how
candy works with different drinks
and how it dissolves,
and why it dissolves.
Science is everywhere.
It's in trees, grass,
dirt, the whole earth
and the sky, so science is everywhere.
>>Klaus: I started a drone explo,
the idea of opening their eyes
to the possibility of, like drones can
really help you do a lot of things.
>>Set it down, okay.
>>You have a brain break.
The idea of them moving to a different
teacher, it's really, really beneficial.
>>So, Elizabeth, what
drone did you develop?
>>Elizabeth: I put on cameras
on each side, so that like,
they could get it from all angles.
And I also put like a
camera in the middle.
>>Klaus: If I say, "Okay, we're going
to spend twenty minutes doing math
and then we're going to just
do twenty minutes of drones,"
but I'm still going to teach math.
So what that does is it opens
up the diversity of curriculum,
so we get to develop something
that starts off from the ground.
>>You guys ready to fly a drone?
>>Students: Yes.
>>Student: Whoo-hoo!
>>Katie: When the kids
come in and they're able
to choose what they're going to learn
about, they're much more engaged.
They're much more likely to go and read
some more nonfiction articles based
on the topic that they were studying.
It's all about engaging students and
getting them excited about learning.